thanks to endo Chino for keeping legal
eagle in the air and helping me look fly
the Senate impeachment trial of
President Donald Trump has begun and day
one was filled with fireworks bombshells
lies and deception things that bode well
and terribly for your case whether you
are a Republican or a Democrat there was
something for everyone so let's dig into
all of the craziness that happened on
day one and let's also find out why
senator Ted Cruz apparently is singling
me out
for trolling hey legal eagles it's time
to think like a lawyer because the first
day of the impeachment trial in the
Senate was filled with all kinds of
lawyer skills and complete sophistry so
let's dig into some of the more
important things that happened during
the first day because a lot has changed
and it's going to set the tone for the
rest of the impeachment trial the first
day of the trial was ostensibly about
setting the rules for the rest of the
trial and indeed they did in fact set
some ground rules for the rest of the
trial interestingly in the run-up to
this first day of the Senate trial
Senate Majority Leader Mitch McConnell
had said that he was going to pattern
the proposed rules off of what was used
in the impeachment impeachment trial the
idea being that if it was good for the
trial of a Democratic president it would
be good for the trial of a Republican
president as well the proposed rules had
been held back and it was only over the
weekend that we got to see what the
proposed rules were going to look like
and interestingly McConnell had made
several key changes to what was proposed
compared to what was used during the
Clinton impeachment trial for instance
two of the major key changes included
that all of the argument would have to
be compressed into a 24-hour period
spread out over two days and that the
evidence that came from the impeachment
hearings in the house would not be
admitted automatically into the Senate
trial
those were big deviations compared to
the Clinton era rules but interestingly
it seems that those changes were
repealed at the last minute after a
meeting with some of the more moderate
Senate Republicans so now the rules that
were approved on a strict party line
vote require that the argument be made
over a three-day period which is
commensurate with what happened
in the Clinton trial but also that
evidence from the impeachment hearings
in the house can be admitted into
evidence in the Senate however with one
big caveat that is a deviation from the
Clinton trial that the evidence is
subject to objections from the White
House or other senators including
hearsay which is problematic to say the
least now of course the Senate can make
whatever rules it wants it can adopt the
federal rules of evidence or not but
what we've seen is that there are plenty
of misunderstandings about what hearsay
actually means and we've covered some of
those misunderstandings on this channel
it's going to be problematic because
here a lot of the testimony that is
relevant to the president's motivations
and the president's actions are
necessarily going to include things that
other people have said those things for
example what the president told Rudy
Giuliani or Mick Mulvaney those things
are relevant in and of themselves as
legal acts which would defeat an
argument that their hearsay but even
things that Rudy Giuliani told other
people including potentially Lev partes
and other associates of Giuliani and the
president would potentially be
considered hearsay but they would be
admissible in court if it were in actual
court because they are declarations
against interest or declarations of a
party there's all kinds of reasons why
even quote hearsay evidence would come
in so the carve out is particularly
interesting from legal perspective but
it is ripe for abuse because people
simply don't understand sometimes
willfully don't understand the idea and
concept of hearsay especially in this
context and as I mentioned it was a
straight party-line vote 53 Republicans
no defections 247 Democrats no
defections now not only did the Senate
procedural rules cover the amount of
time given to both sides to make their
case and their defenses and the
admission of evidence that was procured
during the house impeachment proceedings
but it also covered the new evidence
that will be added to the Senate trial
or more specifically it did not cover
the evidence that will be added to trial
for all intents and purposes the Senate
is kicking that question down the road
though that's not necessarily the end of
this story the Senators can always pick
up this question
with some of the more moderate
Republicans arguing that they will make
a second decision once they have heard
all of the argument from the house
managers and the president's defense
attorneys and that does comport with
what happened in the Clinton trial where
that decision was not made upfront but
was made several weeks into the Senate
trial though it's also possible that the
Senators will not take up this question
again and there will be no additional
new evidence in the Senate trial which
raises the specter of what commentator
Dalia lithic sort of summarized the
Senate GOP position as it's too late for
impeachment witnesses and it's also too
early for impeachment witnesses that
Senate GOP has been arguing that the
witnesses should have been called in the
impeachment hearings in the house and
that it's also too early to address that
question in the Senate and also by the
way no witnesses should be allowed in
either the impeachment hearings in the
house or in the Senate impeachment trial
either and the Republicans argue at the
same time that the Democrats should wait
for the courts to decide these questions
of the subpoenas themselves and whether
the witnesses can be compelled to
testify at the same time arguing that
the courts have absolutely no right to
decide these questions because of
separation of powers issues it does
often feel like the arguments are that
it's never the right time and it's never
the right forum to decide these
questions again in strict party line
votes the Senate Republicans voted to
dismiss 11 amendments that Senate
Minority Leader Chuck Schumer tried to
add to the Senate rules each of which
attempted to bring in various kinds of
evidence into the Senate trial including
subpoenas for documents and witnesses
from the White House these amendments
would have approved subpoenas for things
like communications between the White
House and Ukrainian presidents olenski
documents and testimony from individuals
like acting chief of staff Mick Mulvaney
Secretary of State Mike Pompeo and
former national security adviser John
Bolton and in a really interesting
gambit one of the amendments would have
allowed Chief Justice Roberts to make
the call as to which subpoenas for
testimony and documents would be
approved but again along strict party
line votes the Republicans voted not to
allow any new evidence to come in and
vote it down an amendment that would
have vested the power to decide whether
new evidence would come in with the
Chief Justice presiding over this trial
the next set of fireworks came from the
Democrats who came out swinging and
arguing substantive points on the first
day of the trial now by all accounts it
was thought that everyone was simply
going to discuss the procedure and
procedural rules that were going to
govern the rest of the Senate trial the
Democrats used their time in their
opening statements to talk about the
substantive arguments for impeachment
whether you like this tactic or you
found it to be complete history Onix
this is an interesting and classic trial
tactic to use all of the time that you
have allotted in front of the Trier of
fact or the Trier of lie to get your
point across this is something that
happens in lawsuits and trials all the
time I've seen it many times where
lawyers argue with a judge digging
straight into their arguments when the
judge doesn't really have any idea of
what they're talking about whereas if
you give some background and argue a lot
of your substantive points upfront then
the more nuanced points that you might
make later on will actually resonate
with the judge who has a million things
on their docket and the the tactics that
Adam Schiff and some of the other
Democrats took on the first day of this
Senate trial sort of harken back to that
particular trial tactic that instead of
simply arguing the mere procedural
points which they eventually did
especially with Chuck Schumer they took
that opportunity to start making their
case in front of the senators and the
American people so whether you liked
that tactic or not whether you thought
it was pure grandstanding or you thought
the Democrats were making some good
substantive points it has its basis in
classic litigation and trial tactics to
be able to get your story out at every
Avenue that you can and not just be
cabined into the specific issue in front
but to be able to talk about all of the
issues at the same time because of
course if you have a theme you want to
reiterate that theme or that narrative
as many times as you can hoping
it will stick and of course it was
interesting to compare the Democratic
narrative which went into the
substantive issues with the narrative
put out by the lawyers for the president
who it appears were prepared to argue
for the substantive points but perhaps
not all of the substantive arguments on
day one which leads me to the next part
of this impeachment trial that really
struck a chord with me as a practicing
lawyer was the marathon nature of this
particular proceeding this may be a
feature not a bug when you're in trial
the judge sets the schedule and there's
a reason why often trial starts at 10:00
a.m.
and wraps up by 4:00 p.m. with maybe two
to three hours of substantive things
actually happening during the day and
the reason is that the jury will get
fatigued over time it's really really
hard to be glued to your seat for a full
business day listening to all of these
really complex and arcane arguments and
of course the same thing is in effect
with the Senate trial as well this day
one of the trial went long into the
night and unless you are a legal freak
like me you probably had better things
to do during the day than to watch 12
hours of testimony and argument on
c-span that has an effect it's very
clear that both sides are going to get
fatigued that the American people are
going to get fatigued and that cramming
so much into one day it's it's gonna be
hard to follow all of the different
things that are happening and things are
gonna get chopped up into sound bites by
both sides has to be really hard to pay
attention as the week's go by and this
continues now one thing I thought was
particularly interesting is that both
sides both Republicans and Democrats are
arguing that these impeachment
proceedings both in the House and the
Senate are precedent shattering and are
hugely different from everything that
has come before and in some respects
they're definitely both right and one of
the reasons for that and one of the huge
reasons why the evidentiary issues are
so incredibly important in these
impeachment proceedings compared to
impeachment proceedings in the past is
that there was no independent
investigation by necessity the house had
do the investigating which is really not
set up to do and is bound to get locked
up in separation of powers issues in the
only two other modern examples of
impeachments we had an independent
council doing the investigating in the
Nixon era we had special prosecutor Leon
Jaworski who was able to do a thorough
investigation into the Nixon affair
including being able to subpoena
documents and testimony from individuals
which admittedly went up to the Supreme
Court which forced the White House to
turn over the famous Nixon tapes and
that's one of the reasons the
investigation took years to complete in
the Clinton era we had Independent
Counsel canister who again had the full
force of the executive branch to do an
investigation into the various Clinton
affairs often when you're talking about
impeachment in the house the analogy is
made to the criminal context where the
impeachment is in indictment there is
some investigation but often you are
waiting for additional evidence to come
out through further investigations where
the trial in the Senate is like a
criminal trial in real life where it can
use the evidence that was found in the
house impeachment indictment so to speak
like a grand jury investigation but more
can come out during the Senate trial
itself that analogy is probably a good
one but in practice what we have had is
in the last two impeachment proceedings
there was a thorough investigation done
before it ever got to the trial in the
Senate and of course when it comes to
the Nixon affair it never even got to
the trial in the Senate and house
manager Adam Schiff made this point on
the floor of the Senate during the first
day of the trial when he said that the
Clinton impeachment trial was more about
recalling witnesses than it was about
calling witnesses in the first place so
regardless of which side of the aisle
you happen to stand this is very
different in it may be different out of
necessity because we don't have an
independent counsel one was not
appointed by attorney General William
Barr and we don't have the same kinds of
laws that would have appointed a special
prosecutor like Leon Jaworski to do the
investigation that the house necessarily
had to undertake which is very very new
of course another legal bombshell came
actually from the defenders
of the President and may have severe
repercussions for ongoing litigation
because the president's defenders argued
that the Democrats should have waited
for the courts to decide a lot of these
evidentiary issues and procured more
evidence in the house before going to
the trial in the Senate the thing is
there's active ongoing litigation over
the subpoena to former White House
Counsel dawn McGann the White House has
argued that the courts have no business
adjudicating the White House's refusal
to turn over dawn McGann for testimony
the DOJ as recently as last month argued
that courts can't adjudicate the
privileges used for separation of powers
issues the thing is on the floor of the
Senate the president's attorney Jay
Sekulow argued that Democrats rushed
things and should have waited for the
judiciary to weigh in the rush to
impeachment to not wait for a decision
from a court on an issue is important as
executive privilege
the president's opponents in their rush
to impeach have refused to wait for
complete judicial review other lawyers
for the president are in court saying
the exact opposite of what they're
telling you today they're saying you
cannot enforce congressional subpoenas
that's non judicial that is such a
stunning admission and contradiction
that if I was one of the lawyers working
on that particular case the Don Magan
case I would probably file an emergency
motion with the court of appeals saying
that the Trump administration is
basically conceded the issue and at the
court of appeal needs to compel the
testimony of Don began now there's sort
of a pet theory going around the
internet that Chief Justice Roberts as
the presiding judge over this trial can
save a lot of these issues and can rise
up and can prevent some of the
obfuscation from the Republicans I would
say that that theory was dealt a serious
blow during the first day of the trial
when Roberts really didn't do anything
and wasn't even given some of the power
that the Democrats want him to receive
and that Roberts is really just going to
try to disappear and fade into the
background like his predecessor William
Rehnquist did really the only thing that
Chief Justice Roberts did on the first
day when he chose to speak was to dress
down both sides and say that neither is
upholding the decorum that is required
for these proceedings I think it is
appropriate at this point for me
to admonish both the house managers and
the President's Council in equal terms
to remember that they are addressing the
world's greatest deliberative body one
reason it has earned that title is
because its members avoid speaking in a
manner and using language that is not
conducive to civil discourse but that's
sort of par for the course that's what
you would expect the Chief Justice to do
to fade into the background and let the
political bodies deal with the political
questions so I would expect more of the
same more fading into the background and
both sides in all the issues of course
in one of the biggest surprises senator
Ted Cruz apparently singled me out by
intentionally misusing the famous table
pounding quote you know there's an old
saying that if you have the facts you
bang the facts if you have the law you
bang the law if you don't have either
you bang the table now of course I can't
be certain that senator Cruz is singling
me out by misusing a quote that I've
used many times on this particular
channel but he really does feel like
he's turning it on its head when the
Democrats whether you liked it or not
spent hours upon hours talking about all
the evidence that the White House is
holding back the fact that they haven't
produced a single document or allowed
any White House witnesses to testify in
the House or the Senate
whether you liked it or not they were
talking about the substance of our
gyun's and making use of the evidence
and law that is relevant to this
particular case and of course the
craziest thing of all is that wow this
is all going on in the u.s. President
Trump is in Davos where he gave a press
conference where he specifically bragged
about how he is not giving the Democrats
any evidence and that he's holding it
all back we're doing very well I got to
watch enough I thought our team did a
very good job but honestly we have all
the material they don't have the
material now if I was trying to be
charitable here I would say that
President Trump is just saying that all
of the evidence is in his favor but he
specifically uses the word material
referring to the actual physical things
themselves and not their metaphorical
significance we have all the material
they don't have them at
so it really does seem like the
president is bragging about obstructing
Congress and preventing them from
getting any of the relevant evidence and
not the fact that he's just bragging
about how the evidence supports himself
it really is sort of hilarious that the
president always seems to say the quiet
part out loud and by hilarious I mean
that in the saddest way possible so the
Democratic argument often boils down to
saying that the president is a liar liar
and his pants are on fire and if his
pants really are on fire then he should
really buy some new ones so mr.
president if you're looking for a custom
slim cut suit that is shockingly
affordable I can't recommend endo Chino
highly enough all of my suits are now
made by Indochina including this brown
checked three-piece and if this suit
looks familiar it's because I
unapologetically stole the design from
Blake Scott like just know that
imitation is the highest form of
flattery there's just one thing I wanted
to change though I wanted to change the
lapel from a notch to a peak and with
Indo Chino not only could I choose the
fabric so it was exactly the same but I
could tweak it so that it was a hundred
percent my own and a hundred percent
custom which is exactly what I did see
the secret to a great suit is all about
the fit I'm a reasonably athletic guy
and I can never buy suits off the rack
because they just simply never fit right
if the shoulders fit the waist is too
small it either doesn't fit or it costs
a ton to have a tailor fix it after the
fact but with endo Chino you can send in
your measurements online or you can go
to one of their stores and have a
stylist take your own specific
measurements I made an appointment I
went to a store in person and had a
stylist work with me for over 90 minutes
to make sure that my fit was exactly
right
my personal stylist took my measurements
and a couple of weeks later I got the
best fitting suit of my entire life it
was perfect right out of the box
endo Chino will make you a fully custom
suit tailored specifically for you for
less than $400 and the best part is they
still use the best materials like super
140 s wool and cashmere in fact legal
eagles can get any premium Indo Chino
suit for only three hundred and fifty
nine dollars that's three hundred and
fifty nine dollars for a custom suit
that you design yourself all you have to
do is use the link in the description or
use the promo code legal eagle at
checkout using the link in the
description really helps out this
channel I will never buy an off-the-rack
suit again and once you try it neither
will you
click on the link in the description so
do you agree with my analysis do you
think we'll see new evidence in the
Senate trial leave your objections in
the comments and check out this playlist
over here for all of my other real law
reviews where I talk about impeachment
related things copyright all of the
legal issues in the news where I will
see you in court